sometimes things do not go according to
plan well we've all been there
and that is where we wanted a drew over
that's right because we pun my name with
everything and the holidays are right
around the corner
if you celebrate christmas you know how
important it is to pick out a tree and
after i got this video of a dad who has
five kids
well let's just say i needed to
intervene take a look
hi drew my name is kylon i'm a dad to
five amazing kids they are my heart
we live here in charleston south
carolina it's the holiday season
i work a lot around this time of the
year i haven't really been in the
christmas spirit this year i haven't
really been in the mood of doing any
decorating
i did get my kids a tree though they
like to treat
but i want them to have a normal size
tree something that we could put gifts
under and decorate with a
big star on the top of it i'd really
appreciate your help drew
thank you kylon is joining us hi
on here on zoom hi kylon
[Applause]
okay first of all before i even get into
it will you please come back and do our
gdp program
good dads program um i
have watched your videos i saw the
pre-interview you guys did
i just have to say to you beautiful
kids that you are just listen i'm sure
it's rambunctious and chaos sometimes
but
your dad must be doing such a good job
because you guys are such
good kids
oh you really are okay um
what do the holidays mean in your house
kylon
the holidays mean family time
giving instead of receiving helping
others that are
well unfortunate um you know and just
spending time with family friends and
enjoying the beautiful women in
childhood
well oh charleston i love charleston
um tell me about the tree you currently
have
here's the tree right here
we like it but
um you know i didn't really want to
decorate this year i work a lot
i didn't really want to do anything i
wasn't in the holiday spirit but i got
the little treat
but we would like a normal-sized
fun tree uh my dream tree would be like
a white tree with a lot of colors on it
lights ornaments and a big gold star top
okay perfect so i had heard that request
that you had so our producers
alex carr jessica yank lunas and sarah
our amazing designer
we created this christmas tree for you
it is all white
and the ornaments are toys for your kids
and the lights also i didn't know this
check this out the lights go from white
to hold on this isn't going well oh to
multi-colored
yes you can have it all and then there
are some more gifts under the tree
to have the kids open them up and then
we reached out
uh to ferguson a company that cares so
much about
everybody working in trade professions
during this time
so today they're going to gift you and
your family
all the gifts on this tree as well as 7
500
to just i know
i know i love your family so much
you're such an incredible dad you kids
are just so amazing i have two kids
and i'm telling you as a mom i know
how kids behave all right you guys are
little saints and little
angels and your dad is doing a fantastic
job and so
is your mom and you guys are just
amazing and i just want to say
i fell in love with your guys's story
will you please come back on the show
yes ma'am all right this is all on the
way to you guys